And the last and the most interesting
condition for congruence of triangle is
called the R A condition the other conditions we have seen
so far have n s and n a in their names but this one is a
bit
different ok s as we know stands for side but what
About r and a r stands for
right angle this tells us that the condition will work only
for right triangles and what do we
have opposite to the right angle if
the hypotenuse that stand this
with figures
suppose we have one right triangle a s with
angle  A C is equal to 90 degrees the length of the
hypotenuse is 5 units and that of the height
is 3
units Similarly if we have a right
triangle p which has a right angle at vertex q
with the same hypotenuse will be
congruent we don't even need to know the
Length of the other side and any other angle for that matter we can be sure that these two right three angles are congruent the
hypotenuse
and one side of one triangle are equal to that
of the other does it have to be the
height let's assume that the  Lengths of Side
BCR-ABL Noise That the Two Right Triangles Should Still
Be Congruent
[Music]